let me ask you another sort of
philosophical type question but not
really actually
um it seems that thought experiments are
used so it's not just mathematics that
makes progress in theoretical physics
but thought experiments do they did for
Einstein as well they did for a lot of a
lot of great physicists throughout
history over the years how is your
ability to generate thought experiments
it's just your intuition about some of
these weird
things like quantum mechanics
or string theory
or quantum gravity
or yeah even general relativity how's
your intuition improved over the years
have you been able to make progress the
hard part in physics
is
most problems are
uh
either
doable most problems the theoretical
calculation that are theoretical
physicists would do there there's no end
of problems
whose answer is uninteresting
can be solved but the answer is
uninteresting
there's also no end of problems that are
very interesting
some of which you've asked me but we
don't have a clue how to solve them
when first presented with the problem
almost every problem is one or the other
it's it's the jackpot when you find one
that isn't one or the other
and uh it seems like there's a gray area
between the two right that's where you
should be looking
well I wouldn't describe it as a gray
area I would describe it as a knife edge
this is a very small small area there
isn't like a huge area with a side here
like problems that are doable and people
want to know the answer and that's in
some deep sense that's where timing is
everything with physics with with
science with Discovery timing I mean I
think earlier in my career I I aired
more on the side of
problems that were
not solvable
the ambition of Youth
yeah what what what made you fall in
love with physics
at first if we can go back
to the early days you said black holes
were there in the beginning
but what made you do you remember what
really made you fall in love you know I
wanted to I wanted to reach nirvana and
I sort of realized that wasn't going to
happen and then after that I wanted to
know the meaning of life and I realized
I wasn't
probably wasn't going to figure that out
and then I wanted to like
understand you know
Justice and socialism and World things
and
couldn't figure those out either and the
simplest smaller and smaller problems
I mean most of this stuff talking about
adolescence you know but but but it was
the biggest problem
that I thought that there was a prospect
of
but not a hundred percent you know and I
was definitely
ready to
spend my
my life in the wilderness knocking my
head against the wall but
I haven't
had to
I haven't solved them but
I've said enough interesting things that
you're you're you're you're interviewing
me so so I'm not in the wilderness but
yeah so do you remember the the early
days do you have you feel nostalgic when
you think back to the ideas the
circumstances that let down that led you
down this
the path
towards black holes those theoretical
physics towards the tools of physics
towards this really fascinating world of
theoretical physics
well I wouldn't I wouldn't
add Nostalgia to it because
it's not like a
you know
a summer in Italy or something it's it's
like there there's
there there's results that are there
that that people are and that's what's
that's what's so gratifying
I mean of course one's name
disappears from these
these things
um unless you're Einstein or Newton or
something you're people are not gonna
remember my name in 50 years almost no
basically every name would be forgotten
in hundreds of years yeah yeah are you
able to by the way
um love the idea the exploration of
ideas themselves without the names yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying so I have
not I hope someday but I have not
um you know there are some experiments
now to verify some of my
predictions about you know properties of
gravity and so on but I I have not like
you know most of what I've done is in
the you know it could happen still it's
still a logical possibility that
everything having to do with string
theory and the uh I mean as I as we
mentioned I'm betting the farm that it's
not but but it is a lot indeed a logical
possibility that that people always say
can you believe
Lex Fred men interviewed Elon Musk and
Kanye West and
and he interviewed strominger who was on
this
this working on this theory that just
completely went into the yeah it
completely went into the toilet you know
I'm gonna make I'm gonna get uh well the
wife I don't have and make a public
statement should be on stage I'll say
I'm really sorry I made this giant
mistake
of platforming
this wild-eyed physicist that believe
for decades in the power of theoretical
physics yes no like you said so that
could happen it could happen it could
happen it's it's in the and of course if
that couldn't happen yeah it wouldn't be
real exploration right absolutely and um
so but I I you know I do take a lot of
satisfaction that some of the things I
discovered are
at the minimum mathematical truths and
they're still so you don't have that
sort of nostalgic feeling of it being
something that was
gone and and uh and I'm still making
discoveries
now that I'm as excited about we'll see
if they
hold the test of time that
that stand the test of time that these
other ones did that but that I'm as
excited about as I
was about those when I when I when I
made them I am easily excitable as my
friends will tell you well one
interesting thing about you is and I
have been very excited about things
which turned out to be completely wrong
you know well that's the the excitement
is a precondition for uh for
breakthroughs
um but you're also somebody like just
like you said you don't have a cynical
view of the modern state of physics so
so there's a lot of people that glorify
like the early days of string theory and
that you know all these yeah there's
always yeah yeah yeah but you're saying
like this this to you uh might be one of
if not the most exciting times to be a
theoracophysicist like uh when uh the
alien civilizations 500 years from now
that visit Earth will look back they'll
think the 21st century some of the
biggest discoveries ever were made they
have a when they have a measurement of
string theory the fund's over
then we have to go on to something new
you know no there's deep there's oh
there's going to be the fun is over oh
man
um but there is an end to the Nile right
I mean there that's there's is there
who told you
some some whiteboard guy uh